If you’ve ever woken up from a night out
with mystery
We’re all pretty familiar with bruising.
A bruise is what happens when you break the
capillaries just under the skin through some
trauma, like smashing your leg into a coffee
table.
It’s a small amount of non-lethal internal
bleeding.
And like a cut, platelets rush to the site
of the bruise and stem the flow.
The blood clots, keeping the bruise localized.
Once there’s a pool of blood, immune cells
called macrophages digest the blood to clear
up the bruise.
Their byproducts are responsible for a bruise’s
characteristic colour change from the initial
dark purple to that gross yellow-brown before
it totally fades.
But why do some people bruise more frequently
and more easily than others?
Aside from being clumsy, of course.
Well, there are some pretty common reasons
for increased bruising.
Both age and sun exposure can make the skin
thinner and weaken capillaries making trauma-based
bruising more likely.
People with higher body fat can be more prone
to bruising, but so are in-shape athletes,
but not just because they hit themselves with
barbells.
Which is a random example, totally never happened
to me.
Okay, I hit myself in the face with a barbell
once.
Maybe twice.
Don’t judge.
Anyway, exercise breaks apart muscle fibers
under the skin, and these ruptures are tiny
traumas that can lead to a bruise.
And if your black and blue mark is lasting
longer than normal, it might be because you’re
taking certain drugs or supplements.
Blood thinners like aspirin, anticoagulant
medication, and antiplatelet agents will make
you more likely to bruise from trauma.
These medications don’t break capillaries,
but they do limit your blood’s ability to
clot so any internal bleeding can spread further
and take longer to heal.
It doesn’t necessarily increase the chances
you’re get a bruise, it just means that
bruise will last a little longer.
But all of these causes of bruising demand
trauma, like smashing your shin on a coffee
table, basically something that breaks capillaries.
If you’re bruising without making contact
with a table, you might have a pretty serious
underlying condition, like a bleeding disorder.
Bleeding disorders are a type of disease wherein
the body doesn’t produce enough of the blood
proteins or platelets that are needed for
blood to clot, or those that are present don’t
function properly.
Haemophilia and von Willebrand disease are
two familiar inherited ones.
These disorders can make a bruise last longer;
blood can’t clot so bleeding persists.
They can also lead to spontaneous bruises
without trauma on a part of the body that
doesn’t normally bruise.
A sudden black and blue mark on your abdomen,
for example, can be a sign of something far
more serious.
These kinds of non-trauma induced bruising
could mean you may have an acute or chronic
infection like sepsis or a chronic disease
like lupus or cirrhosis that affects clotting,
something you could have been born with or
developed later in life.
You might also be malnourished.
Vitamin B12, C, or potassium deficiencies
can lead to increased sporadic bruising.
So at the end of the day, bruising is pretty
normal, especially if you’re a klutzy gym
rat.
But frequent bruising or ones that last a
long time, can come down to a lot of different
things.
The moral is: listen to your body!
If a part of it changes colour, maybe find
out why.
Minor bruises are known to clear up quickly,
but it never hurts to visit your GP if you’re
concerned.
Some bruises come with GREAT stories!
And no domain extension will help you tell
your story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain
name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
Seeker.com
Have you seen the all-new Seeker.com yet?
The site is home to all of Dnew’s episodes,
plus articles, photos, and more great video
about science, the world, and exploration.
Click the link in the description below, and
tell us in the comments what news or stories
you’d like to see more of.
What other weird body mysteries would you
guys like us to dig into?
Let us know in the comments below, don’t
forget to like this video, and subscribe!
so you never miss an episode of DNews.